which character from the creepy werewolf
By Night Special could be gunning for
Marvel's most famous vampire Hunter
signs seem to be pointing to one in
particular Marvel Studios cracked its
monsterverse wide open with the
frightening holiday treat werewolf By
Night the black and white splatterfair
space homage to Cinema's earliest
monsters and sets the Marvel Cinematic
Universe up for more thrilling Bloodshed
the Disney plus original series Moon
Knight was definitely a first step in
this spooky Direction leaving room for
more iterations of creature features
featuring characters including Ghost
Rider death lock and perhaps even
Marvel's version of Dracula Marvel
Studios has definitely dipped its toes
into some more horror styled content
recently it even recruited veteran
horror director Sam Raimi who brought
some small hints of horror to his Sony
Spider-Man movies in the early 2000s for
wonders terrifying massacre in doctor
strange and the Multiverse of Madness
these elements lay The crucial
foundation for Marvel's more horrific
adventures and prepare audiences young
and old for more nightmare air inducing
moments who said they had to be living
the studios phase 4 has included a
number of different genre experiments
the company's ability to adapt to
different styles is a promising sign
that it is hungry for fresh and exciting
tales and it's an excellent time to
speculate where the universe could be
headed next before Marvel was the
Cinematic Juggernaut it is today it did
see some success in the horror realm
with the blade movie trilogy starring
Wesley Snipes as a stylish vampire
Hunter Marvel worked with new line
Cinema on the films starting with 1998's
blade but by the time played Trinity
came around in 2004 it seems the series
had won its course Marvel also teamed
with Sony to bring one of its 1970s
comic book monsters to the screen with
2007's Ghost Rider starring Nicholas
Cage despite doing reasonably one of the
box office it was a dud with critics
with a Rotten Tomato score of 27 the
Ghost Rider sequel 2012 spirit of
Vengeance was met with even worse
reception from critics in Rotten
Tomatoes score was 18 it also did
considerably worse at the box office
this understandably left the Marvel
Studios hesitant to return to the
Flaming headed biker or to fully Embrace
horror an iteration of Ghost Rider did
show up in Marvel's Agents of Shield
television series to set up his own show
but following Disney's acquisition of
fox his spin-off show was axed luckily
that wasn't Marvel's last try at
bringing the horror comics of the 1970s
to life on screen werewolf by Knight and
Moon Knight have inspired confidence in
Marvel's die-hard horror fans the
werewolf slasher even introduced the
odd-looking man thing Paving the way for
other scary characters including the new
blade call him by his name which is Ted
he's called Ted viewers first encounter
with the mcu's new version the blade
came at the end of eternals in a
post-credits scene Dane Whitman is seen
inheriting his family's precious and
deadly sword the Ebony Blade this also
indicates that comic book fans that
Whitman will become the Avenger of Black
Knight when Whitman picks up the sword
an instantly recognizable voice cautions
sure you ready for that Mr with me the
Dark Sword carries unspeakable
consequences mahershala Ali's blade for
warns or the Ebony Blade possesses
extraordinary power it also drives the
user mad over time causing them to
commit heinous acts Blade's warning
suggests he may team up with the black
knight in his upcoming solo film which
could even feature a formidable foe seen
in werewolf By Night Elsa Bloodstone
made a fiery entrance as he Unapologetic
and fearless daughter of Monster Hunter
Ulysses Bloodstone she unflinchingly
survived both the Bloodstone hunts and
her encounters with man thing and the
Werewolf himself Jack Russell her
capable display of skill is even more
exciting after she obtains the
Bloodstone and her powers becoming one
of the mcu's deadliest vampire Hunters
while blade and Elsa may share some
similar goals blade status as a day
Walker could set up a potential clash
between the two Slayers of course if
they do meet it's likely they'll have to
team up to take on a bigger threat
[Music]